you
I'm an idiot my entire mixer was off
sorry guys
okay let's take it from the top if we
can Wow things are getting crazy I
apologize I've been a quarantine and I
guess one of the side effects is you
don't you don't turn the mixer on when
you're self quarantine and running the
equipment yourself okay we are on now
thank you we are here waiting for the
Donald Trump press briefing on
coronavirus at the bottom of the hour we
have multiple streams trained on
everything that is going on the there is
a hypothesis this was originally
scheduled for earlier today and there's
the idea that Donald Trump once again
has decided to put it right near the
close of the stock market today to try
to save what is again a 2000 point
decline a 9% decline in the stock market
as you can see here at the open stocks
immediately dropping within a minute
stocks were closed that's why it's just
a horizontal line there the the the
circuit breaker was triggered the idea
is Trump's going to try to come out and
say something to salvage the trading day
and not lose again another 8 to 10
percent so as when Trump speaks we are
going to keep an eye on it you see that
it is off of it's very very lows earlier
and sort of since what time was this a
couple hours ago has been sort of
increasing we don't know where the day
will end but there is no question that
part of the timing of this certainly
planned to try to save another
disastrous stock market day we are going
to look at some of the latest numbers
and then we will we will hear the press
conference at the bottom of the hour
thank you for joining me I do want to
hear from you so if you have anything
you want to get on on the record about
what's going on if you're watching on
youtube use the super chat function your
messages will show up in that very
sad-looking gray bar at the bottom it's
empty because nobody has said anything
yet and if you're watching on Twitch
make sure to include a message because
it'll show up in that vertical blue box
and then I'll read your message or
question and and and address it here if
you're just joining us on YouTube I
do ask that you hit like and subscribe
it does so much for us and I just did a
search for Trump coronavirus livestream
so we came up second and the more people
like our streams it's incredible how
YouTube very quickly says this is the
stream to recommend and that listen if
we're all gonna be stuck inside together
doing this stuff your help in growing
our channel is always very very much
appreciated inconsolable is kicking us
off with a $50 super chat saying I'm in
Seattle and I'm terrified countless
people have lost their jobs and can't
pay rent food we've been told to expect
a curfew in statewide food shortages ubi
is literally the only thing that can
save us now our government has failed us
yes and specifically Trump's government
Trump of course disbanding the pandemic
Response Team and on and on and on I
think you guys know know about all of
that stuff at this point it is getting
scary and I have a lot of people I'm in
touch with personally who are scared
Massachusetts our governor Charlie Baker
has announced starting tomorrow bars and
restaurants can only be open for takeout
and delivery I believe they are
instituting an 11:00 p.m. curfew which
is like what does it even matter if you
can't go in who cares how long how long
they stay open 25 people is the maximum
allowed for gatherings of any kind
starting tomorrow a lot of states are
doing this this is going to [ __ ] the
economy this is going to lead to more
and more trading days like this and
people's retirement accounts and the
like will suffer there is no question
the question is how can we most
efficiently save as many people as
possible and get back to some sense of
normalcy and that the point I made today
and you can kind of see this when you
look at coronavirus cases if you look at
for example you know maybe South Korea
is a good example every day that we
don't start fixing it is another day
that we need to fixes so in the sense
that if you look at North South Korea
not North Korea we don't know what the
hell's going on there every day that
cases go up you need a day on the
backend for cases to go down
we delay three days it really costs to
six if we delay six days it really costs
us twelve because you eventually get to
these inflection points and the backside
is just as long as the build and that is
what is so important to understand the
the mathematical impact of quickly
dealing with it is it's Pat of paramount
importance
it truly is John McKinney says have you
ever read Dracula by Bram Stoker I I've
not I'm not
Alan sack says Biden's looking better
and better every day
listen guys I I think it's over I know
some people are mad at me but look at
the polling for tomorrow inconsolable
says bars and restaurants closed in
Seattle to ironically Inslee and other
governor's seemed the most presidential
people right now a lot of governors are
taking the lead the idiotic governor
spit his names like Jeremy's tit or
something like that Brad's tit something
like that in Oklahoma
you guys have guys an idiot I'm not even
gonna talk about what he's doing but
some governors are doing the right thing
knowledge gizmo says Rodney Romney
proposed $1000 stipend
sounds like socialism yeah how come we
know can we afford that guys no listen
Mitt Romney's not wrong what you need to
do is get money to people that's the
issue that we have a lot of people you
know we're so lucky here at the David
Pakman show where we've been able to
decentralized production
everybody gets to keep working you know
we may suffer some consequences as a
result of you know advertisers may want
to wait on campaigns because of
coronavirus or stuff like that but we're
lucky that we can do this and we can
keep working a lot of people can't a lot
of people are not in that situation and
you you know people are going to need
money in order to afford their their
basic things if you're just joining us
we're 20 minutes 25 ish minutes from a
donald trump coronavirus task force
press briefing at the bottom of the hour
and we're gonna hang out and talk to you
guys until it starts paradox
Zoroark has grabbed the twitch Prime
subscription as has ghost noted and day
to forget thank you guys I appreciate
that if you're just joining us on
YouTube please make sure to LIKE the
stream and hit that subscribe button
would very much appreciate it
parrot
hiren says andrew cuomo's live show was
quite good did you see it
I didn't we were we were taping today's
show at the time swing blitz says be
kind to grocery workers worked 55 hours
this week yes indeed yes indeed
Mike Z or sorry satirical Symphony says
David how come no one's talking about
Chinese billionaire Jack Maas offered to
send the u.s. 500,000 testing kits masks
and ventilators haven't heard of it I
will look it I will look into it
Mike Z says I hope he orders a national
shutdown we need it it's sad but at this
point we probably do Tony says
Minnesota's governor waltz is doing an
amazing job I've read that in Minnesota
they're doing you know within reason the
best the best that it that is possible
to do and everybody is in a very very
tough situation again we believe that
Donald Trump rescheduling this press
briefing for 3:30 is designed partially
to try to say something that much like
last Friday will boost the stock market
which is down another 9% I've lost a lot
of money in the last three weeks and
this it's not about me it's about people
closer to retirement who have lost money
it's about it's about a lot of different
things but I relate to you my personal
story just just for the sake of it if
you look at actually I can show you my
Twitter there is me working from home
earlier today please consider retweeting
my tweet we are doing everything we can
here at the David Pakman show to just do
what we're being asked to do we don't
have to go in so we're not we took the
weekend to decentralize production and
we've done it and you know there is me
on my laptop doing my thing and we've
really moved production equipment we are
decentralizing all of it and we'll do it
for as long as we need to that's that's
the reality so you know it it feels
surreal to some degree but we're trying
to be as much a part of the solution as
we can rather than a part of the problem
let me say thank you to deathly for
signing up with a Youtube subscriber
that which subscription I appreciate
that this is
the new reality for a while until it
changes and we just don't know how long
that's that's going to be Bobby clay
sends a super chat Marika says the
Finnish Swedish and Danish governments
put together economic support for
individuals and businesses to get
through this finland shuts down
wednesday listen at this point i think
if you delay the shutdowns you're only
extending how long this is going to go
it's it's going to have to happen at
some point
and again we're waiting on i have a
pretty comprehensive segment on today's
show which hasn't published yet about
the three paths of research vaccines
antivirals and antibody treatments and
all of them are a ways away so for now
all we can do is stay away from people
that is all that we can do kevin vang
says how are we going to get paid how
are we going to stay safe from shooting
each other from starvation will the
government force us to pay our monthly
fees during this plague i don't know
what monthly fees you mean they're
suspending interest on student loans
there's the idea of doing something on
mortgages a lot of this stuff again is
up in the air and we're expecting donald
trump to announce some more stuff at the
bottom of the hour inconsolable says i
know we don't have the data because the
government failed to react but it seems
like reaction to the disease and the
economic impact is going to kill more
people than the disease itself
well the spread of the disease that was
not necessary is going to kill a lot of
people that's for sure thanks also to
Rio to die for subscribing with twitch
prime I'm sorry for subscribing with
YouTube let me take a quick look to see
if NBC is live with Trump coronavirus
because they sometimes give us video of
what's going on in the room which we
sometimes prefer no we're not seeing
that if at any point somebody finds a
stream where they are live in the room
so we can actually see what's going on
please do let me know I would appreciate
that last time it was an NBC but they
don't they don't seem to be live right
now we do have a modest membership goal
I
appreciate that everybody's been
supportive of the the hours and hours
and hours of streams we've been doing
around this and other issues including
pre and post shows yesterday consider
grabbing yourself a membership at join
pakman.com info is right above my head
it's very easy we've got a coupon code
that'll save you 66 percent every time
someone signs up this blue bar which is
a very sadly at zero that's so sad to
see it's at zero right now every time
somebody signs up on my website it
starts creeping across and ideally we
would fill it with 25 new members at
join pakman.com just a thought just an
invitation consider yourself consider
yourself invited other super chats
coming in let's see here Andrew Bogart
says Alabama residents still don't
respect the pandemic yeah we are seeing
a drastic difference between the blue
states and red states between
Republicans and Democrats in terms of
whether they even believe what is going
on and that is going to be a problem
there are countries where people are
taking this seriously and there are
states where people are not and that's a
major major problem for us we've got a
hype train happening on Twitch very
exciting a rich ropa thak says
inconsolable is a Backstreet Boys song
proud straight male fan very good thank
you for letting me know
knowledge gizmo says explain what the
hell foreseeable future even means I
wish I knew yeah like I said I posted
this picture to my Twitter which I
invite you to like and retweet and I say
we are decentralizing production of the
David Pakman show for the foreseeable
future I don't know what that means I
think it means in the absolutely most
hyperbolically optimistic side two weeks
up to three to four months I mean I just
don't know I don't know I don't know I
don't know how long it's going to be but
it's going to be a while that's for sure
Bobby clay says the analogy analysis I
just read said that global recession is
already a fact because of a 20% drop in
Chinese GDP yeah I think we're in a
recession that that's that's my son
of it John McKinney says do you like
gothic novels
not really no that's not not really a
that's not really a genre that I look at
very closely let me say thank you to
Chris Jones Chris just grabbed a
membership at join pakman.com Chris you
are new member number one today and I
really do appreciate your support I also
want to say thanks to Phyllis Miller who
is new member number two today at join
pakman.com really appreciate you signing
up we are just about 15 minutes from the
start of this press conference if you
are just joining us on YouTube please
make sure to LIKE the stream and to
subscribe and what's amazing is when you
do that if I search let's test it if I
search right now Trump coronavirus live
and we sort only buy live events our
stream is oh dear it's nowhere it's like
ok it's like 7th when a bunch of people
like and subscribe very often our stream
will come up in the top three and as you
can imagine that just builds on itself
as more people search for these streams
I would rather people watch it with our
commentary that let me give you an
example of how crazy things are
Breitbart is doing a stream don't go to
it don't do please don't abandon whoa
before you go anywhere
Breitbart I I read is doing a stream
with commentary of what's happening at
the bottom of the hour they will just
amplify the disinformation propaganda ok
let's not allow that to happen let's
make sure we like and subscribe this
stream so that people will be directed
here as opposed to some of these other
very toxic toxic places ok um let's see
other super chats that are coming in oh
and over on Twitch sacred light has
grabbed a Prime subscription makkal and
grungy Dan have cheered its alias TV has
grabbed a subscription as well all very
much appreciated John ok John McKinney I
dealt with already clever to swear
are still waiting for that children of
the lie debut talk to Anthony Fanta no
Stephen Kenneth destiny bonel the second
and Sam cedar I've already said I'm
doing it but I need their I need their
participation
Brody Andrew Mulligan says I'm a private
music teacher no pay will the government
help I certainly hope so
and I don't know the answer Jack Maxwell
says I'm in a conservative area of
Canada and we are taking it dead
seriously it's the u.s. that
disproportionately has this we have two
viruses in the United States we have
coronavirus and then we have the
disinformation propaganda virus that
includes people like Devon Nunez saying
restaurants will be easy to get into go
to a restaurant Fox News saying this is
a great time to fly there will be no
lines so we have two two different
viruses and one virus has infected
disproportionately conservative voters
and it may be terminal it may be
terminal maybe not for them but it's
going to kill other people that's the
crazy thing that we're dealing with
Adams W says I highly recommend reading
an American sickness by Elizabeth
Rosenthal but the US healthcare system
love to hear your thoughts if you've
read it I haven't I'll check it out care
Evita so seriously what the hell with
Trump trying to buy exclusive rights to
the vaccine this man is the definition
of chaotic evil yeah I have a big
commentary about that coming up today on
our YouTube channel so I won't i won't
preempt it because III already I did a
commentary Evan Lewis asks what will
true will Biden choose for VP I think
the most likely people would be Amy
Klobuchar or Kamala Harris maybe there's
something in there with with Elizabeth
Warren but I'd be pretty surprised
Dinkins has grabbed a soy boy membership
JD says can trump stop the market
downturn listen I don't know that he can
really stop it for good but one of the
reasons I believe he rescheduled this
speech to 3:30 it was originally going
to be 10:30 then we heard 2:30 now it's
starting at 3:30 is I believe he wants
to talk
up the stock market we are now down nine
and a third percent which would be one
of the biggest declines going all the
way back to the Great Great Depression
not recession depression in the 1920s so
I think Trump's idea is that he can talk
the stock market out of this decline let
me say thanks to Lycan GTV for giving
out five subscriptions on Twitch as well
as call Color Me boom oh sorry I have a
bunch of new website subscribers oh ok
so we're trying to get to 25 new members
on my website and we've got a bunch of
people to thank here
let's see Gregg Pelerin is new member
number three today Jay Spann Bauer is
new member number four today I'm feeling
good about the pronunciations on names
until now hold on Don and Jay seth is
new member number five today samuel
Rocha is new member number six Aaron
Barnes is new member number seven we're
still doing okay mark Barnett is new
member number eight today Kathleen
Demery is new member number nine at join
pakman.com and Daniel Lang or land
always hard to know I believe its Lang
is new member number ten today at join
pakman.com if you're just joining us
welcome on youtube twitch and facebook
live we are waiting for the bottom of
the hour we do now have live video from
the room we see I believe this is CNN's
Caitlyn Collins here filing some kind of
live report and we are presumably just
minutes minutes from the start of this
coronavirus press briefing every
expectation that Donald Trump is going
to try to talk the stock market out of a
10% decline we will see if he can do it
we will see if he can do it thanks for
joining us and of course make sure if
you're watching on twitch we're only a
hundred and fifty followers from 30,000
consider following and if you're
watching on YouTube listen we can all do
our part we've reorganized our
production to decentralize it so we can
work
you can like this stream and subscribe
to my channel on YouTube every one of us
has has a part to play okay super chats
continue to come in what do you think of
Trump trying to buy the vaccine I have a
video coming out on that at 4:00 p.m.
Adam the D says buy stock calls or puts
before the speech it will move a lot
ice-cold enema
says why do we care about old people all
of a sudden to a degree of limiting
personal liberties is it because
politicians themselves are old I just
care about people so that that's it I
mean for me it's it's quite simple
quit bitching says do an episode on the
nation of Taiwan's response I will look
into that looks like we are starting
let's see what's going on
Secretary General this incredible liar
dr. Sima Burma that other doctor Anthony
pouchy the Admiral as Trump referred to
him so we are getting very very close to
this starting presumably just waiting
for
I believe Trump and pence will be here
although sometimes you don't know
sometimes it's just pence and then you
know it's a [ __ ] show we will see in the
meantime thank you - oh boy now it's
gonna get a little difficult with the
names
Karthi karun Denis D is new member
number 11 at join pakman.com Sean Leske
is new member number 12 at join
pakman.com Andrew Bogart is number 13
and there is Donald Trump it does look
like downer Trump today just from what
I'm seeing so far but we will very soon
see you glad to see that you're
practicing social distancing that's
exploring there it's very good
I want to thank everybody for being here
today this morning I spoke with the
leaders of the g7 g7 nations this
morning as they really had a good
meeting I think those are very very the
other one may be louder let me see nope
we're gonna stay over here about every
American to follow over the next 15 days
as we combat the virus each and every
one of us has a critical role to play in
stopping the spread and transmission of
the virus week we did this today this
was done by a lot of very talented
people some of whom were standing with
me and that's available okay he made a
paper and dr. Burks will be speaking
about that in just a few minutes it's
important for the young and healthy
people to understand that while they may
experience mild or sonorous symptoms
syndra can easily spread this virus and
they will spread it indeed putting
countless others in harm's way we
especially worried about our senior
citizens the White House Task Force
meets every day and continually updates
guidelines based on the fast evolving
situation that this has become all over
the world so all over the world we know
it's incredible what's happened in such
a short period of time yeah you deny the
lines of the task force the new modeling
conducted by dr. Burks and our
consultation with governor's we've made
the decision to further toughen the
guidelines and blunt the infection now
we'd much rather be ahead of the curve
than behind it well you're behind
therefore my administration is
recommending that all Americans
including the young and healthy work to
engage in schooling from home when
possible home school avoid gathering in
groups of more than 10 people 10 ployed
discretionary travel and avoid eating
and drinking at bars restaurants and
public food courts wow this is national
name if everyone makes this change or
these critical changes and sacrifices
now we will rally together as one nation
well the market crash will repeat the
virus and we're going to
have a big celebration all together with
several weeks of focused action we can
turn the corner and turn it quickly a
lot of progress has been made I'm also
pleased to report today that a vaccine
candidate has begun the phase 1 clinical
trial this is one of the fastest vaccine
development launches in history vaccine
Phase one loss we're also racing to
develop antiviral therapies and other
treatments and we've had some promising
results early results but promising to
reduce the severity and the duration of
the sin of the symptoms and I have to
say that our government is prepared to
do whatever it takes whatever it takes
we're doing we're doing it in every way
and with that I'd like to just introduce
dr. Burke who's going to discuss guys
notice no bragging no bluster this is
Trump realizing how serious it is he
stopped the bragging about how great we
are I think you know over the last
months we've taken very bold action to
stop the virus from coming to our shores
and because of that we gained time to
really get together and understand the
progress across the globe of what has
worked and what hasn't worked we now
need to appeal to every single American
so that they can have their role in
stopping the spread of this virus we've
talked about things before about washing
your hands but we really want to focus
on if you are sick no matter who you are
please stay home if someone in your
household is diagnosed with this virus
the entire household should quarantine
in the house to prevent spread of the
virus to others the reason we're taking
these strong and bold steps is because
we know there is virus spread before you
develop symptoms and then we know that
there's a large group we don't know the
precise percent yet that actually is
asymptomatic or has such mild cases that
they continue to spread the virus
correct if your children are sick please
keep them home
now to our older population or those
with pre-existing medical conditions
everyone in the household needs to focus
on protecting them everyone in the
household I want to speak particularly
to our largest generation now our
Millennials I have the mom yes -
wonderful millennial young women who are
bright and hardworking and I will tell
you what I told to them they are the
core group that will stop this virus
they're the group that communicates
successfully independent of picking up a
phone they intuitively know how to
contact each others without being in
large social gatherings we're asking all
of them to hold their gatherings to
under 10 people not just in bars and
restaurants but in everywhere we really
want people to be separated at this time
to be able to address this fire as
comprehensively that we cannot see for
which we don't have a vaccine or a
therapeutic the only thing we have right
now
is the amazing ingenuity and compassion
of the American people this is serious
we're appealing to all Americans to take
these steps to protect each other and to
ensure that the virus doesn't spread
these guidelines are very specific
they're very detailed they will only
work if every American takes this
together to heart and responds as one
nation and one people to stop the spread
of this virus thank you
this is scared trumpets he gets very
much dr. Burks so just to connect with
what I mentioned to you in previous
discussions in this room and dr. Burke
said it very well that in order to be
able to contain and curtail this
epidemic to not reach its maximum
capability
we have a two pillar approach one of
which I believe has been very effective
in preventing the substantial seating
and namely the travel restrictions that
we've discussed many times in this room
the other equally if not more important
is when you have infection in your own
country which we do and you know I could
be that a numbers but they're really
essentially what we've seen yesterday
incremental increases both globally as
well as in the United States with the
curve doing that
so therefore the kinds of things that we
do are containment and mitigation this
what we're mentioning now the guidelines
when you look at them carefully I
believe if the people in the United
States take them seriously because they
were based on some rather serious
consideration back and forth some may
look at them and say they're gonna be
really inconvenient for people some will
look and say well maybe we've gone a
little bit too far especially right-wing
they will well thought out and the thing
that I want to be emphasized and I would
say it over and over again when you're
dealing with an emerging infectious
diseases outbreak you are always behind
where you think you are if you think
that today reflects where you really are
that's not word speak it means if you
think you're here you're really here
because you're only getting the results
therefore it will always seem that the
best way to address it would to be doing
something that looks like it might be an
overreaction yes it isn't an
overreaction it's a reaction that we
feel is commencement which is actually
going on in reality so take a look at
the guidelines read them carefully and
we hope that the people of the United
States will take them
very seriously because they will fail if
people don't adhere to them we have to
have as a whole country cooperate and
collaborate to make sure these get done
thank you part of the reason we don't
have the real numbers is we're not
testing if Americans really were to band
together I do what the White House is
suggesting how quickly you could turn
this my favorite question asked it all
the time how many times Anthony I think
I asked him that question every day and
I speak to Deborah I speak to a lot of
them I just get the opinion so it seems
to me that if we do a really good job
will not only hold the death down to a
level that is much lower than the other
way had we not done a good job but
people are talking about july-august
something like that so it could be right
in that period of time where it I say
wash it washes through Trump's talking
about the 5 min term 500 washes through
this the new normal until Hiva so we'll
see what happens but they think August
could be July Wow to be longer than that
but I've asked that question many many
times yes stocks about to implode
Americans yep there they go looking
forward or living with so much anxiety
and so much fear facing uncertainty
right now I'm curious how are you
talking to your own family about this
how are you talking to your youngest son
do you empathize with this sense of
anxiety people are really scared yeah no
I think they are very scared I think
they see that we're doing a very
professional job we've been working with
the governors and the frankly the
mayor's local government at every level
we have FEMA totally involve him has
been you know usually we see FEMA for
the Hurricanes and the tornadoes now we
have FEMA involved in this they've been
doing a fantastic job locally working
with people that they know because they
worked like as an example in California
in the state of Washington and they work
with them a lot on other things and
they're very familiar so they're working
on it
what you can do and all you can do is
professional totally confident we have
the best people in the world we have
really the greatest experts in the world
and someday soon hopefully it'll end and
we'll be back to where it was but just
came up but it's crashed so suddenly
look he was surprised we were all
surprised we heard about it we heard
about reports from China that something
was happening and all of a sudden we did
make a good decision we closed her our
borders to China very quickly very
rapidly there was a I was a otherwise
would be in a hurry as Estonia said
numerous times we'll be in a very bad
position much worse than we would be
right now you look at what's happening
in other countries Italy is having a
very hard time but I think that I think
that what we do and I've spoken actually
with my son he says how bad is this it's
bad it's bad but we're going to we're
going to be hopefully a best case not a
worst case and that's what we're working
for yes
some confusion on two key fronts one is
about your own test the other is about
containment efforts is the
administration considering more
aggressive containment options like a
quarantine a national curfew well we
have that very much yeah we have that
very much and we are we've been pretty
aggressive we were early with Europe but
we were very very early with China and
other places not the question
fortunately we were and as far as
containment here we are we're coming out
with strong suggestions and you know
it's becoming a little bit automatic you
look at people they're not doing certain
things for instance it obviously not I
wouldn't say the restaurant business is
booming in bars and grills and all
people are self containing for to a
large extent we look forward to the day
where we can get back to normal are you
considering instituting a nationwide
lockdown a nationwide quarantine the NSC
knock that down but there's still some
questions about how it all at this point
not nationwide but well there's some
point you know some places in our nation
that are not very effective their fault
but we may we may look at certain areas
certain certain hotspots as they call
them made you lock down with that but at
this moment no we're not Friday night
though the White House doctor's office
put out a statement around midnight
Friday saying that no test was indicated
so when exactly was your test
administered well I had my test I was
late Friday night and the reason I did
it was because the I had no symptoms
what so the doctor said you have no
symptoms so we don't see any reason but
when I did the press conference on
Friday everybody was going crazy did you
do the test did you do the test so very
late on Friday night I did the test but
that's one day now he was a clear
outdoor the doctor may have put out
something at I don't know what time the
letter went out maybe it was put up by
somebody else but Oh had the results
came back I believe the following day
and we tested negative wait a sec White
House doctor's office a test was
implying that you hadn't had one when in
fact you had well I told them that and I
went totally by what they said the doc
knows more than one who believes that
they said you don't have any of the
symptoms they checked what you're
supposed to check and that I didn't have
symptoms but I did it I did a test late
on Friday night and it came back
probably 24 hours later or something
they sent it to the labs came back later
yeah president I think that was the
nation's governor's today and even a
teleconference you told them if they
need things like respirators or masks to
try to get it on their own what did you
mean by that they can get them faster by
getting them on their own in other words
go through a supply chain that they may
have because the governor's you know
during normal times the governor's buy a
lot of things not necessarily through
federal government if they are able to
get ventilators respirators if they're
able to get certain things without
having to go through the the longer
process of federal government we have
stockpiles now or we're ordering
tremendous numbers of ventilators
respirators masks and they're ordered
and they're coming and we have quite a
few at this point I think Mike we have a
lot but if they can if they can get them
directly it's always going to be faster
if they can get them directly if they
need them and I've given them
authorisation to order directly market
in free-for-all bikes
witnesses in our health care system is
search capacity for medical facilities
and I wanted to ask what precautions
what what plane is being done
to get China was able to build hospitals
in a matter of days are you prepared to
use the corps of engineers or FEMA to
start building search capacity that we
may need in a couple weeks so first of
all we hope we don't get there and
that's what we're doing and that's why
we're taking a very strict look at this
but we also are looking at areas and not
only looking we're expanding certain
areas we're taking over buildings that
aren't used we're doing a lot in that
regard we hope we don't have to get
there but we are doing a lot in that
regard
no one should worry about losing a
paycheck if they stay home when they're
sick but the House bill exempts
companies of 500 employees or more from
the paid sick leave requirement and
that's 54% of the American workplace why
is it a good idea to only require small
businesses to provide me well we look
into that and we may be expanding that
we are looking at that we want fairness
we want it for everybody no we're
looking at that through the Senate
because as you know the Senate is now
digesting the question so we may very
well be hitting something
right now and will I could get back to
you with that number we've ordered a lot
we have quite a few but it may not be
enough and if it's not enough we will
have it by the time we need it hopefully
we won't need them we'll give you we
could give you a number if it's
important we'll give you another day
yesterday you said that this was under
tremendous control do you want to
revisit that statement we are going to
be experiences experiencing this until
July or August five more months I'm
saying we are doing a very good job Wow
confines of what we're dealing with
we're doing a very good job there's been
a there's been a tremendous amount of
The Lying the way they're working
together they're working hand-in-hand I
think they're doing really a great job
and from that standpoint that's what I
was referring to yes I'm not referring
to it meaning the AH yeah if you're
talking about the virus no that's not
that's not a really place in the world I
think you are talking about what we're
doing is under control but I'm not
talking about the virus yes please
market took another hit today is the US
economy heading into a recession well it
may be they're not thinking in terms of
terms of the virus once we stop I think
there's a tremendous pent-up demand both
in terms of the stock market in terms of
the economy and once this goes away oh
dear it goes through and we're done with
it I think you're gonna see a tremendous
tremendous going to be a collapse any
domestic travel restrictions I know
that's been on the table before but
we're not really we hope we don't have
to see if we we think that hopefully we
won't have to do that but it's certainly
something that we talk about every day
we haven't made that decision
[Music]
doctors and nurses in this country are
telling us across the board they're
terrified of this virus of the fact that
they don't get it or the fact that they
might take it home to their families
what can you say to assure health care
providers in this country that the
federal government is doing something to
day to ensure that they get personal
protective equipment to protect
themselves and their family well I think
the federal government's doing
everything that we can possibly do we
made some very good early decisions by
keeping people out by keeping boy
countries out certain countries where
the infection was very immense I noticed
a lot of people are talking about South
Korea because they've done a good job on
one side but on the other side
tremendous problems at the beginning
they had tremendous problems and great
numbers of death I think that we've done
it a fantastic job from just about every
standpoint with that being said you look
no matter way you look this is something
it's an invisible enemy and but we are
speaking all the time not only with the
people but also the professional people
the nurses the doctors they have been
doing a fantastic job we are also
working very much on getting them the
kind of equipment that they need and for
the most part they're either they either
have it or they will be getting it but
remember this we want the governor's we
want the mayor's we want them locally
from a local standpoint because it can
go quicker we want them to work and we
we had a great talk with the governors
today I think it was a really great talk
there's a tremendous coordination
there's a tremendous spirit that we have
together with the governor's and that's
pretty much for the most part bipartisan
yeah you just you told John that you
think this could wash through as you
said July August you just told Steve
when he asked you
about a possibility of recession you
said it may be curious if there is a
recession when do you think that might
be well I don't I don't number one
determine recession I just say this we
have an invisible enemy we have a
problem that a month ago nobody ever
thought about nobody in a you know I've
read about it I read about many years
ago 1917-1918 I've seen all of the
different the different problems similar
to this that we've had this is a bad one
this is a very bad one this is bad in
the sense that it's so contagious it's
just so contagious sort of
record-setting type contagion and the
good part is the young people or they do
very well and healthy people do very
well very very bad for older people
especially older people with problems
my focus is really on getting rid of
this problem this virus problem once we
do that everything else is going to fall
into place yes last night that you were
gonna put in a national curve for you
yeah or something I've been watching
right exactly me too your people were
saying this is a foreign disinformation
campaign if that's what's going on are
people messing with us on the Internet I
don't know I mean that I can't tell you
if they are or not I think a lot of the
media heck actually has been very fair I
think people are pulling together on
this I really think the media has been
very fair I think it could be that you
have some foreign groups that are
playing games but it doesn't matter we
haven't really determined to do that at
all and hopefully we won't have to
that's a very big step it's a step we
can take but we have not decided to do
it Jennifer go
mr. president the president thinks on
one on Airlines and will Jeff Bezos can
you talk a little bit specifically about
what you'd like to do to help the
airlines first of all and then second of
all we heard that Jeff Bezos has been in
contact with the White House daily can
you say what he's been asking for
proposals well I've heard that's true I
don't know that for a fact but I know
that some of my people of as I
understand have been dealing with them
or with him and that's nice we we've had
tremendous support from a lot of people
this is a new Trump guys can help and I
believe he was one of them as far as the
airlines are concerned the airlines
we're going to back to the airlines 100%
not their fault it's nobody's fault
unless you go to the original source but
it's nobody's fault
and we're going to be in a position to
help the airlines very much we've told
the airlines we're gonna help them well
we're gonna help me we're gonna be back
stopping the airlines we're gonna be
helping them very much jobs very
important $25 per passenger carriers and
four billion for cargo we're gonna be
looking at it very strongly we have to
back the airlines it's not their fault
in fact they were having a record season
everybody was there having record
seasons and then this came out and it
came out from nowhere so not their fault
but we're gonna be back in the airline
yeah let's continue to fall today would
the White House support best thing I can
jump in the stock market is we have to
get through this crisis that's what I
can do that's the best thing we can do
that's what I think about once once this
virus has gone well I think you're gonna
have a stock market like nobody's ever
seen before
he'll be back in a second get me back to
second I think the question that I think
maybe John asked about until July the
guidelines are a 15-day trial guideline
to be reconsidering it isn't that these
guidelines are now gonna be in effect
until July what the president was saying
is that the trajectory of the outbreak
may go til then make sure we don't think
that these are is solid in stone till
July outside I think it even better look
they're working together very well with
the house they're working very much in
unison like the question before they're
working to it only enhance it and make
it better and make it fair for everybody
and that's what we're looking to do so
we may go back and forth with the house
a little bit but both will be in a very
positive fashion please these new
guidelines say avoid social gatherings
and groups of more than ten people the
CDC's recommendations yesterday work for
people to avoid gatherings
more than 50 people what's evolved and
you and your team's thinking in just the
past 24 hours
and also what exactly do you need to see
us well let me just have the
professionals thank you then thank you
for that question so we have been
working on models day and night around
the globe to really predict because some
countries in our very early stage like
the United States we've been working
with groups in the United Kingdom so we
had new information coming out from a
model and that what had the biggest
impact in the model is social distancing
small groups not going in public in
large groups the most important thing
was if one person in the household
became infected the whole household self
quarantine for 14 days because that
stops a hundred percent of the
transmission outside of the household
and as we talked about early on it's
silent we had another silent epidemic
HIV and I just want to recognize the HIV
epidemic was solved by the community the
HIV advocates and activists who stood up
when no one was listening and got
everyone's attention we're asking that
same sense of community to come together
and stand up against this virus and if
they everybody in America does what we
ask for over the next 15 days we will
see a dramatic difference and we won't
have to worry about the ventilators and
we won't have to worry about the ICU
beds because we won't have our elderly
and our people at the greatest risk
having to be hospitalized
yes Thank You mr. president
very productive call today with
governor's we talked about the new
rollout of testing that we described
yesterday and drive through in
community-based testing and I know how
grateful the president is for the the
efforts that governor's are making and
now with the Admiral and the United
States Public Health Service as well as
FEMA we made great progress today and
coordinating those efforts but the other
issue that was raised for the president
today was personal protective equipment
and the reason I mentioned testing is
because one of the recommendations that
we have for States is that these remote
testing sites make a priority of two
groups one would be people over the age
of 65 that have symptoms we don't want
them to go to hospitals or emergency
rooms we want them to go to a remote
site in a parking lot or at a isolated
community location but the other
category is our health care workers we
want to make sure their health care
workers have the opportunity to be
tested and using that new a
high-throughput test that the president
arranged with our major commercial labs
we'll be able to do that much more
expeditiously so we're putting a real
priority on our extraordinary health
care workers that are that are at this
very hour coming alongside people that
are struggling with the corona virus and
people that are concerned that they may
have been exposed the other piece is
we're grateful that the legislation
passed by the House of Representatives
includes a liability protection for n95
masks produced by companies like 3m in
Minnesota by Honeywell literally tens of
millions of masks are produced every
year for industrial purposes for
construction but the health experts say
they can be used just as readily to
protect healthcare workers from
respiratory ailments 3m and other
companies were not able to sell those to
hospitals but the president negotiated
with the Democratic leadership of the
House and Senate we've added a provision
to the bill that will literally from one
come
ellone add another 30 million masks per
month back to the marketplace we're
strengthening the supply chain and
healthcare workers around America can be
absolutely certain that the President
and our entire team are going to
continue to put the health of America
first and put first our health care
workers across this country that are
meeting the needs of the people of our
country have been sent out and how many
people can actually be tested so thank
you very much for that as we talked
about yesterday we're really entering a
new phase of testing at first we were at
the initial phase where the CDC
developed test was only available in
public health laboratories in the CDC
works very well for a few thousand tests
per day after it gets running we're now
moving into a phase that the big
commercial laboratories with high
throughput screening have availability
so as we talked about last week because
of the historic efforts of the FDA a
Roche test and as the president
predicted a thermo Fisher test we're
both produced last week under an
emergency use authorization 1.9 million
of those tests will be sequentially into
the ecosystem this week from the
information we have right now
1 million tests are available with all
the reagents everything ready to go
primarily at the reference labs called
quest lab core and a couple others now
it doesn't matter if they are not in
your neighborhood because every day when
people get tests a little white box goes
out in front it gets shipped by an
incredible distribution system the test
result and it's electronically reported
so these are available to people
nationwide we expect more and more than
1 million coming on board this week as
the reagents come up in his people with
the testing capacity validate that in
their own hospitals and other and other
places and in the future we expect at
least 2 million next week and at least 5
million the week thereafter there are
also a whole
both of what's called laboratory
determined testing or laboratory derived
testing where individual laboratories
because of the regulatory deregulation
of the FDA can develop their own test
and start using them so if you're a CLIA
certified lab with complexity you can do
that so the point is testing is now
entering sort of what we normally do in
the healthcare system where big labs in
a high-throughput basis receive these
through normal channels so that part of
it is really underway how many Americans
have actually been tested you haven't
known there is a number I don't have
that number because I've been working on
setting up this distribution system so
this is where we are the state and
public health laboratories in the CDC
are published every day on the CDC
website the CDC gets feeds from lab from
LabCorp and quest and they get that on a
daily basis what is not being received
right now in ambassador birx
is fixing is that these homegrown tests
in highly complex labs don't necessarily
get reported in the system however as we
move forward particularly in the high
into the commercial phase of where we
are right now we expect about 80 to 85
percent of the tests to flow right into
the CDC we know them that's not good
enough for ambassador Burke she wants
100 and we'll work on that so I think
just to put it a different way of a lot
of testings have been going on and I
don't believe anybody has been able to
do what we're doing and what we will be
doing and well know that we talked about
the drive through testing yesterday I
want it to be clear to everybody this is
just another tool for states in local
public health systems and healthcare
systems to use it's not replacing
testing that it goes on in a doctor's
office or in a hospital or if you go to
your doctor and wants to get tested in
that office this is just another tool
that we're hoping the states to have and
again as we talked about this is modeled
on the FEMA base points a distribution
system optimized for testing we expect
this week we now have
Geir people being shipped right now
today that will be in over 12 states
with multiple sites many of many of
states having multiple sites to start
augmenting the local capacity and really
providing the state and the local people
what they need as another way for people
to get tested before that's never been
done and certainly not on a level like
that and I think I can speak for the
professionals that if you don't have the
symptoms if your doctor doesn't think
you need it don't get the tests don't
get the tests I think it's very would
run out and get the tests actually we
should be testing large asymptomatic
populations New York said that he
believes that Hospital hospital capacity
soon will be overwhelmed and implored
you to call on the Army Corps of
Engineers to build temporary facilities
to house patients is that something
we're looking into it we've heard that
we've heard it from really two places
there are two places that have
specifically New York being one and we
are looking into it very slowly
yeah strong are you washing your hands
were always wash my hands a lot I wash
my hands a lot probably a baby of
anything more certainly not less now not
something I want to do every day I can
tell you that it's you know it's a
little bit of a it's a little bit of
good doctors in the White House but it's
a test it's a test it's a medical test
nothing Pleasant about
in a tweet that Governor Cuomo should be
doing more
what's why I think you can't do what
specific I think you can't do more and
you know it's an area of the country
that's very hot right now I think New
Rochelle and playside know very well I
grew up right near New Rochelle I think
it's a it's a very now I think it's an
area that has to be tamp down even more
because it's hotbed there's no question
about it so I think they can look at
doing it but we're getting along very
well we've had a very in fact I noticed
you made some statements just now that
the relationship with the federal
government has been good the federal
government has done everything they've
wanted us to do but we can I think I
think it's very important that all of
the governor's get along very well with
us and that we get along with the
governor's and I think that's happening
and being a bubble to avoid the spread
of the disease and to protect the chain
of command is that something you and the
Vice President should be doing and has
there been any talk about having to have
a 25th amendment we haven't thought of
it but you know I will say this that
it's we're very careful very careful was
with you know being together even the
people behind me are very they've been
very strongly tested I've been very
strongly tested very strong and we have
to be very careful but everybody should
be vigilant we have to be vigilant okay
I don't know if this is a question for
you or for dr. Berg but dr. Berg said
that it is the Millennials who are gonna
lead us through this and that now is the
time to look out for the older people in
our home older might be a state of mind
not necessarily an age so for those
Millennials of us who have parents who
are in their 50s 60s 70s
what is older what should we tell them
at this point
well if I was dr. Falchi I would tell
you there's a physiologic age and a
numerical age so older people with
pre-existing conditions and what do we
mean by that you know significant heart
disease significant kidney disease
significant lung disease any
immunosuppression any recent treatment
for cancer any of those pieces in any
household now why do I think the
Millennials are the key because they're
the ones that are out and about and
they're the most likely to be in social
gatherings and they're the most likely
to be the least symptomatic and I think
we've always heard about the greatest
generation we're protecting the greatest
generation right now and the children of
the greatest generation starting place
the Millennials can help us tremendously
by having a plus they need to
communicate with each other public
health people like myself don't always
come out with compelling and exciting
messages that a 25 to 35 year old may
find interesting and something that will
take to heart but Millennials can speak
to one another about how important that
is in this moment to protect all of the
people now you could be 40 and have a
significant medical condition and be a
substantial risk you could be 30 and
having come through Hodgkin's disease or
non-hodgkins lymphoma and be of a
significant risk so there are risk
groups in every age group but the eight
there's more Millennials now than any
other cohort and they can help us at
this moment mr. president the other day
you said that you were not responsible
for the testing shortfall very simple
question does the buck stop with you and
on a scale of one to ten how would you
rate your response to this crisis
I'd read it at end I think we've done a
great job and it started with the fact
that we kept a very highly infected
country despite all of the even the
professionals saying now it's too early
to do that we were very very early with
respect to China were screened we would
have a whole different situation in this
country if we didn't do that I would
rate it a very very I would rate
ourselves and and the professionals I
think the professionals have done a
fantastic job as far as the testing you
heard the Admiral I think the the
testing that we've done we we've really
took over an obsolete system or put it
maybe in a different way a system that
wasn't meant to do anything like this we
took it over and we're doing something
that's never been done in this country
and I think that we are doing very well
we took the system we worked with the
system we had and we broke down the
system purposely we broke it down in
order to do what we're doing now and
within a short period of time and even
now we're testing tremendous numbers of
people and ultimately you're saying it
will be what it will be up to how many
people will be able to test we certain
we certainly expect with the high
throughput testing that that's no longer
a barrier the barrier is actually doing
the test on a person I'm sure as we know
isn't will would inform you in order to
do the test a health care provider needs
to dress in full personal protective
equipment full personal protective
equipment and there's a swab that's put
in the back of the nose all the way to
the back of the throat it's called a
nasopharyngeal swab which is then put in
media the next person who has to get
tested that healthcare provider has to
change all the personal protective
equipment
when you put that in it's highly likely
a person coughs or sneezes so you're at
risk so that's what we're trying to fix
now by the mobile platforms by all the
things we're doing is to enable sort of
high throughput of this swabbing and
we're doing some technological things
too that might be breakthroughs to make
it much much faster but we certainly
expect that from thousands of people per
day we will we will be at the tens of
thousands of people per day this week
according to those who are
yeah normally but I think when you hear
the you know this has never been done
before in this country if you look back
you know take a look at some of the
things that took place in oh 9 or 11 or
whatever it may have been
they never did nobody's ever done
anything like what we're doing now I
will also say ed well I think we can say
that we're also getting this ready for
the future so that when we have a future
problem if and when and hopefully we
don't have anything like this but if
there is we're gonna be very we're gonna
be starting from a much higher plateau
because we were at a very very low base
we had a system that was not meant for
this it was a smaller system it was
meant for a much different purpose and
for that purpose it was fine but not for
this purpose so we broke down the system
and now we have something that's gonna
be and and is very special and is ready
for future problems I think we can say
that very strongly yes are you two
shutting down America's northern border
with Canada and could you also speak to
the fact about the elections that are
supposed to be taking place tomorrow is
it it your advice that those states
postpone those elections
well I'd leave that up to the states
it's a big thing postponing an election
I think to me that really goes to the
heart of what we're all about I think
the postponing in elections a very tough
thing I know they're doing because
they've been in touch with us they're
doing it very carefully they're
spreading people out very at great
distances as you can see and I think
they'll do it very safely I hope they do
it very safely but I think postponing
elections is a very it's not a very good
thing they have lots of room and a lot
of the electoral places and I think that
they will do it very well but I think
postponing is unnecessary think about it
we think about it if we don't have to do
it that'll be good we have very strong
emergency powers when it comes to
something like this both on the southern
and the northern borders and we we are
talking about different things but we'll
see right now we have not decided to do
that Steve
about you to talk about the vaccine
while today that would be good more
vaccine has is it possible accelerators
are still 1218 thank you for that
question the vaccine candidate that was
given the first injections for the first
person took place today you might recall
when we first thought I said it would be
two to three months and if we did that
that would be the fastest we've ever
gone from obtaining the sequence to
being able to do a phase one trial this
has been now 65 days which I believe is
the record what it is it's a trial of 45
normal individuals between the ages of
18 and 55 the trial is taking place in
Seattle yes there will be two injections
one at zero day first one then 28 days
there will be three separate doses 25
milligrams 100 milligrams 250 milligrams
and the individuals will be followed for
one year both for safety and whether it
induces the kind of response that we
predict would be protective and that's
exactly what I've been telling this
group over and over again so what's
happened the first injection was today
who may have felt sick but then feels
better so you had symptoms but no you no
longer do your fevers going away how
long would you stay home after that
point that's not clear for me well if
you are if you are positive for the
infection if you have corona virus it is
less how you feel then whether or not
you're still shedding virus so the
general issue about letting people out
of a facility who for example a hospital
or whatever who have been infected you
need to negative cultures the same way
that was just described 24 hours apart
the question will take care of itself
the market will be very strong as soon
as we get rid of the virus today the
pregnancy was one of those underlying
conditions do we say that - there's very
little data and pregnant women I think I
about a week ago I said that reports
that came in from China by the Chinese
CDC of the nine women who were
documented to be pregnant and have
coronavirus in their last try semester
delivered healthy children and they
themselves were healthy and recovered
that is our total sample size and we
will be getting more data from countries
while countries are in the midst of this
crisis like Italy it's I try not to
bother them frequently to get us their
data we try to get it just weekly from
the countries that are in the midst of
responding to the epidemics so that
their focus is on their individuals in
their country saying encouraging people
to go out to restaurants which goes
directly against
advice in your guidelines you know I
haven't heard that I haven't heard that
from Devon or anybody else stop saying
that but I have to see what they said
but we disagree with it but right now we
don't have an order one way or the other
we don't have an order but I think it's
probably better that you're done
especially in certain areas it's
actually being responsible in this
problem Oakland to professionals are
saying that's what you're saying in your
guide people say I don't know who would
be best to answer this question maybe
secretaries or doctor pouchy schools
school districts across the country are
closing down yet for the most part
daycare centers remain open and
considering that children can sometimes
be asymptomatic carriers again and go
home to older individuals are there any
recommendations about daycare centers
that's a good question John in in in the
original guidelines as they were they
were presented it was schools not
daycare I think it's very important we
should probably if you have not
discussed I go back and discuss that in
some detail about whether or not that's
equivalent to school it's a good
question
the question about the sort of
underlying public health strategy behind
some of these guidelines telling people
to avoid restaurants and bars is a
different thing than saying that bars
and restaurants should shut down over
the next 15 days so why was it seen as
being imprudent or not not necessary to
take that additional step off at an
additional guy
I think we have to say the data Heather
has been coming out and I'm sure you're
all up to the date up to date on how
long the virus lives on hard surfaces
and that has been our concern over the
last two weeks he was my mentor so I'm
gonna have to let him speak the small
print here it's really small print in
states with evidence of community
transmission baws restaurants food
courts gyms and other indoor and outdoor
venues where groups of people congregate
should be closed are you telling
governor's in those states then to close
all their restaurants well we haven't
said that yet one recommending but we're
recommending things no we haven't gone
to that step yet that could happen but
we haven't gone there yet please on the
election you're saying if you've got the
ten percent maximum you know guideline
in a practical sense can you have
rallies can you primaries short eke out
a long time well hopefully there's gonna
weigh us through and hopefully that will
have everybody will be going to
restaurants and flying and being on
cruise ships at all of these different
things that we can't have the
conventions and it will very very
hopefully be in a fairly quick period of
time but we're taking a tough stance we
may make certain other decisions we may
enhance those decisions we're going to
find out as per the question that you
were asking some of those decisions may
be had so how about one more
yes there any reason to believe that
they were trying to hack into the system
and gather information donuts assume and
also is there any reason so were they
trying to hack to get information or and
also wait do you have any reason to
think that it could have been Iran
Russia do you have any any reason to
believe was a foreign act so in the
previous 24 hours we saw a great deal of
enhanced activity with relation to the
HHS HHS computer systems and website
fortunately we have extremely strong
barriers we had no penetration into our
networks we had no degradation of the
functioning of our networks we had no
limitation of our capacity for people to
telework we've taken very strong
defensive actions the source of this
enhanced activity it remains under
investigation so I wouldn't want to
speculate on the source of it but there
was no data breach or no degradation in
terms of our ability to function and
serve our important mission here one
thing like you said it's very important
to get out that this is for the next
what we're talking about much of what
we're talking about is for the next 15
days my good tested I've not been tested
yet I'm in regular consultation with the
White House physician and he said I've
had not been exposed anyone for any
period of time they had the corona virus
and that my wife and I have no symptoms
but we're checking our temperature
regularly every day and we'll continue
to follow guidance which I think may be
a good a good place to land at the end
of the day and that is as we expand
testing rapidly around the country
through the new public-private
partnership that the president
facilitated we want the test to be
available for people who have symptoms
people that who have symptoms and are in
vulnerable populations and our health
care workers to make sure that they can
have the peace of mind that they're
doing their jobs and they're properly
protected and so our best counsel the
council the experts is if you have a
question call your doctor call your
health care provider ask whether or not
you should be tested and that's what my
family is doing as well
let me just emphasize one more point if
I can the president asked the task force
to continuously review the data and the
information that we have not only in
this country but from around the world
to give the best guidance to state
leadership and local health care
leadership and all of the American
people about how to keep themselves
their family and their community safe
this guidance for the next 15 days is
what our experts say is the best
opportunity we have to lower the
infection rate over the entire course of
the coronavirus just as the president
did by suspending travel from China just
as he did with travel advisories and
screening from Italy and South Korea and
just as we've done with Europe and and
at midnight tonight with the UK and
Ireland will continue to take very
decisive steps to lower the the spread
of the coronavirus but we want every
American to know and we would ask all of
all of you in the media just spread the
word of the American people that this is
advice on behalf of the President of the
United States to every American what you
can do over the next 15 days to prevent
the spread of the corona virus and we're
calling on every American to do your
part because together we'll get through
this and we'll find our way forward
they're still gonna be able to meet at
Camp David as well it looks like it are
you confident in their responses they're
in a position that some of them are in a
rough position if you look at how man
and some are heading toward pretty rough
territory we had a very good conference
it was a teleconference everybody was on
the phone every leader and almost a
hundred percent was devoted to the
subject that we're talking about today
and
they are working very hard and if you
know they're very concerned obviously
but they're working very hard but I
would say just about all of it was Steve
all of it was devoted to what we're
talking baby
I think so I mean you know so far it
seems we have it we didn't even discuss
that it's still a ways off but it was a
very good discussion and they have
there's a great camaraderie there's a
great togetherness I think it was I
think I could say that very very
strongly thank you all very much
thank you what what can we say guys I
mean a very just adjusting my seating
here a very very concerning overall a
big picture for sure and we I I took
notes about everything that was said
before you head out if you are watching
on YouTube but please do me the very
small favor of just hitting like and do
consider subscribing to my channel
we had about 13,000 folks watching on
YouTube during that and before you leave
I really would appreciate just hit like
and subscribe it's a really small ask
and we've been doing hours and hours of
these streams and will continue to and
it just is so appreciated when when
people do that it does help us
significantly same thing over on Twitch
if you're heading out just do hit follow
and by the way for people watching on
Facebook live we do now have facebook
subscriptions available they're just a
few bucks a month you can sign up on our
Facebook channel and support the work
that we do but I invite everybody to
stay I will be taking questions so many
have come in the summary of what was
announced of course these are
recommendations for now not mandates
home schooling children no groups of 10
or more stop travel stop eating out we
are working on vaccine phase one trials
which are gonna last a year according to
Anthony foutch II and antivirals Donald
Trump says this could go until July or
August although these guidelines
initially are for 15 days he is aware of
the possibility of lock downs and they
have none announced yet but are aware
that that's a possibility and Donald
Trump maybe most significantly admitting
number one the virus is not under
control
for the first time Trump saying the
virus is not under control and we may be
in or soon in a recession the stock
market falling lower lower lower during
Donald Trump's speech and then in
after-hours going up a little bit but
this is the endpoint right here and as
you can see from here when Donald Trump
right around here when Donald Trump
started all the way down to here another
very very bad day for the stock market
incredible incredible I do appreciate
everybody who has joined me I by the way
as these press conferences get scheduled
going forward feel free to shoot me an
email through my website to let me know
I'm trying to stay on top of when they
are but I don't always see it I'm busy
producing the show and doing other
things so I always appreciate people
letting me know
hey Trump's doing another one of these I
got such an email today okay let me
answer a few Super chats and then I'll
keep I'll rotate and make sure we hear
from a lot of different people here
clever let's see here Alexei says I'm
immunocompromised and work in an ER my
insurance took me off my monthly
antibody infusions can I be fired if I
request a leave I don't know you need to
speak to an employment attorney I wish I
could give you advice clever to swear
says 3,200 new cases in Italy down from
3,500 we're safe maybe it's an
inflection point Babur's dog has grabbed
a youtube subscription kelly d says we
just had the first coronavirus death in
martinique france is going to
confinement we're waiting for McCrone
speech
Dillinger's see attic says Romney's
proposing a thousand per adult is this
bizarro world it is is Trump screwed if
stocks dropped below pre Trump levels
Trump is screwed no matter what and he
had better hope that he can get this all
together in some kind of serious way
because otherwise we are really in
trouble let me say thank you to some
other folks who have grabbed memberships
I can't tell you how much I appreciate
the support of people who have been
regularly grabbing memberships on my
website join pakman.com
Mary Brown is number 14 today Maria
Carla mano is new member number 15
today Steve Hudson is new member number
16 on my website today
Carol McAra Chur is new member number 17
at join pakman.com shaun overton you are
new member number 18 randon Haim you are
new member number 19 today Vivian
Larranaga is new member number 20 I so
appreciate that Nick Peterson you are
number 21 at joined pakman.com Craig
watt you are subscriber number 22 at
join pakman.com Jamie Thomas is new
member number 23 today
Jesse Black is new member number 24 and
Alexander camp is new member number 25
thank you so much and let's blow right
through that target of 25 over on Twitch
G Money Rider subscribed and said hasn't
Korea fixed these testing problems as
far as I know yes they have that's me
one two three has grabbed the twitch
Prime subscription Ted Ward pio has
subscribed with prime as has alien P
Darius Reggie Asst Deb Saunders gender
ik has cheered a thousand bits and I
appreciate all of that support clever to
swear says I'm hoping more CEOs show up
Musk Bezos etc listen we're going to
need something okay half the country
isn't taking this seriously you can
guess which half the the the social
distancing will not work if half the
country doesn't take it seriously it's
the economy is imploding unless we see
someone come up with something and if
it's going to be private industry we'll
take anything right now okay I hope we
see something inconsolable says we need
less corporate welfare and stock
injections and more individual relief
like universal basic income the BS
belief in trickle-down economics is
going to get people killed yeah Dre wall
in 96 says Cobb feffy 19
other than covet 19 Scott Gord Avett
running any membership coupons yes Scott
right up there the coupon 2020 now it's
been on screen the whole time 20 20 now
saves you 66% at join pakman.com nascent
Nathan Smith David do you believe the
gall of these clowns I believe it
because I'm used to it 35 edu says
vaccine phase 1 yeah right
oh I believe it it's just a phase that
will take a year Rachel Robinson has
subscribed Keith stone says why can he
never seemed to stand still
I donno niandra says keep it up M says
incredible they're putting the onus on
us Millennials so we can be blamed when
it blows up and they can say we warned
you
yeah listen speaking as a millennial by
the way here's me as a millennial
working from home that's a little
something you can retweet on Twitter but
let me give you an example I'm just
scrolling here of what one millennial
here's some Millennials
that's Nashville Saturday night that's
some Millennials that are a problem
here's people of all ages in Brazil here
is another there you go okay so listen
did not everybody's part of the problem
but the point is the people most likely
to not know they are carrying the virus
are Millennials who may be completely
asymptomatic North Korea did extensive
testing of 20 to 29 year olds found a
ton of people who were never at any
point feeling sick had the virus okay I
think what they're saying is important a
sign pimp says stop with the comments
it's annoying okay listen I mean this is
this is a commentary channel Kyle
McMahon says this highlights the utter
fragility of the capitalist system we
need socialism yesterday
III think that it it highlights the
utter fragility of our system
I don't know that socialism is the
answer son ER says stop Trump from
talking or the Dow will crash more
certainly seem to happen today
inconsolable says July or August we'll
be lucky if people can survive until the
end of this month Robyn's tiny homestead
has grabbed a youtube membership let me
look at twitch where Rhapsody's angra's
says I wonder how end of world
doomsayers
are interpreting these events I bet
flipping out I've not heard from them
but listen one thing is I know that
there's some anti VAX the anti-vaxxers
have mostly been keeping their mouths
shut and that's good free party 123 has
subscribed with prime as has that that's
me 1 2 3 and tedward p oh i also want to
say thanks to christian fritz who's new
member number 26 today at join
pakman.com as well as christina dixon
who is noone new member number 27 today
at join pakman.com i so appreciate you
guys signing up and your continued
support there are many free ways to help
us and the quickest and easiest is hit
that like button if you
watching on YouTube and hit the
subscribe button we are actually only
360 subscribers from eight hundred and
fifteen thousand
there's 8400 people watching on YouTube
right now if just like three percent of
you hit subscribe we can get to eight
hundred and fifteen thousand subscribers
like that okay I don't know if my Mike's
picking that up but seriously like and
subscribe
we've thanks to you guys in your support
of these streams even just by liking and
subscribing we've really continued to uh
to build out the viewer base death is a
businessman asks do I think Trump
actually got tested I don't know I
really don't know if you said to me
Trump is gonna be given truth serum and
he will tell you the truth would you bet
he got tested or did that he didn't I
really don't know I I really don't know
what what I would say it's it's very
hard to uh to know wake me up from this
fever dream says skunk games at you know
every more this is an incredible thing
every morning I wake up and there's
about it's sort of like after there's
been a death in the family where
sometimes you will wake up and for its
it's a fraction of a second you forget
what's going on you forget that a loved
one died then you realize it and all the
feelings come in when I wake up in the
morning and it's been beautiful here in
Boston it's sunny I feel well rested all
that stuff there's like a half-second
where I forget what we're dealing with
and then I remember oh right I'm not
going outside I'm gonna have to go fight
for toilet paper and milk and I can't go
and see my parents it's it's incredible
it's really really it's surreal date
Connelly says I want to ask David with
the current incompetence of the
administration do you think we're gonna
get this are not down below one our
hospitals feel doomed to get overwhelmed
I don't know I don't know let's actually
let's let's review let's look at the
growth rate now so are not is the growth
rate of the disease let's look at case
statistics what you will see is the
number of new cases per day continues to
increase that is a very big problem the
growth factor continues to be just
around a little over one and what's
important to understand is the more that
we have active cases right this is the
number oh sorry that's total cases this
nope that's not where is active cases
here's active cases the more if you have
let me give you an example if you have
40 thousand active cases and four
thousand people get infected that's an R
naught of 1.1 okay
the numbers are active the calculations
a little more complex but just imagine
that if you have 80 thousand active
cases or eighty-five thousand
eighty-five hundred new cases is an R
nought of 1.1 so the issue is even with
an R with a growth factor that is not
that much more than one if it doesn't go
below one we're still gonna have
accelerating new cases every day
you can keep a growth factor of only one
point one six which makes you think
we're not that far from getting below
one at which point fewer and fewer
people have the disease you can continue
at one point one six and new daily cases
will keep going up because that's based
on the number of cases up until that
point and that is uh that that's I mean
listen I think you guys all know about
math and data so I don't think I have to
go into into too much too much more
detail there let me say thank you to
Deborah Saunders who is new member
number 28 today at join pakman.com and
Thomas Lewis is new member number 29
today at join pakman.com very much
appreciate the the support I am a data
male I know a lot of people might be
shocked to hear that neo-noir says World
War 1 was a mistake it was a war of
Britain's dismantling Germany for the
wrong reasons that's out of scope it's
out of scope today Charlie says the
correlation between Trump opening his
mouth and stock market's crashing his
astonishing Magga yeah I mean remember
last week when he spoke on Friday he
opened his mouth and stocks went up 10%
so it's it's beyond Trump at this point
lars Morton thew says wow hang on there
1917-1918 did Trump just compare this to
the Spanish flu he seemed to Casey Bates
it's a new
Trump until the conference ends and he
opens Twitter toon Italica breakdown
breakdown ironbark says thoroughly
recommend reading the house on Garibaldi
Street by isser Harel who oversaw the
capture and extradition of Eichmann X
excellent read yeah right now I'm
reading hunting Eichmann by Neil bascomb
and of course Acer Harrell is one of the
people in the book I I've heard my mom
said that that's a good book I'm gonna
read it next 9000 CK says if this is a
new Trump how long do you think he can
sustain it probably a day he's never
been able to resist Twitter tantrums for
more than a week
Shaner says Trump we have a we have a
problem that a month ago nobody ever
thought about I read about it wow just
wow yeah we've known about this for
months
I have clips on my youtube channel that
are months old oh sorry my hair is
getting a little crazy I apologize about
that i-i've you that's better I think
that makes more sense for today anyway
man that is Wow
that is something we've been covering
for a month you're right inconsolable
says you're not looking so good are you
okay yeah I feel fine it's just what's
going on is horrible horrible Paul havoc
has grabbed a subscription neon Noir
asks if I'm religious no I'm not super
chats from a quell and 9000 CK thanks to
dat hamster for the cheer on Twitch
lemon tea lil minty has subscribed with
prime Tom's says David you're the best
appreciate that guys thank you very much
and appreciate everybody watching on
YouTube today as well Cal Torino is new
member number 30 today at join
pakman.com Jared Williams DeBolt is new
member number 31 today at join
pakman.com thanks guys I really do
appreciate the support
I see people asking about the next
stream the next stream is tomorrow at 8
p.m. Eastern Time it will be results
from Arizona Ohio Florida and Illinois
those are the four elections coming up
phone iike the second predicts a
government shutdown in two to four weeks
awesome gaming the Dow is down 13% yes
indeed and it seems to be continuing to
go in post market trading roughly
roughly equal no no change there ACK
well says Millennials run my country
thank God for that
DeAndre Holland Trump can't stop himself
from using helping verbs and
superlatives strongly best very strong
he can't help himself you're right Dave
Connelly
it'll all be okay guys cheetos supreme
said so dream hallo says i want to know
why republicans are still trying to
encourage people to gather in public
places are they trying to get
constituents infected can you imagine if
the reason they're so big on the
primaries happening is they want
democrats to contaminate each other that
would be sick i'd be disgusting if
that's what they wanted let's see here
missed some georgia pool tour Gina Poole
says we can do the convention digitally
how do you do the RNC and the DNC if you
can't meet in person in groups of larger
than ten people I mean it's that this
entire summer is over folks Brandon I'm
a factory worker kovat nineteen has
reached my town should I expect to be
out of work Georgia
I hope not my friend Z jump says destiny
lost this debate Justyna Tyson has
subscribed at the soy boy level
Kelly d-- says this was a fine press
conference I hate Trump but I won't spit
on what I saw today I agree this was a
new Trump check out my Twitter and if
any of this stuff resonates with you
consider retweeting it and by the way
make sure you're following me on Twitter
at D Pakman my brand new professional
headshot is front and center there look
at that that is something that thick
Semitic hair I mean I wanted that to be
a big part of my new professional
headshots
I did say Trump is visibly scared it's
the first time his demeanor symp seems
to match the seriousness of what's going
on
Trump admits the virus is not under
control and we may be in a recession you
can tell Trump now realizes
how serious this is no brat no bragging
no bluster stay home no bars no
restaurants it only took months if any
of this stuff resonates with you by all
means um you you can retweet at large
Ohio primary moved to June is that right
Ohio prime that one is tomorrow Ohio
primary suspended
I'm not does anybody have an article on
that I have not seen that let's do a
Twitter search for that one
Ohio primary postponed Ohio's governor
lieutenant governor are recommending the
primary be postponed they do not have
the power to do so it is in the hands of
the courts guys it's a [ __ ] show it's a
[ __ ] show
it's things are happening faster than
analysis even really is appropriate for
Dow is down twelve point nine three how
is this not a recession it probably is
Vikram Peres who has subscribed SOI
baboso says give it to me straight David
how [ __ ] are we quite quite T Mac has
subscribed on Twitch prime and says a
trump run lockdown sounds terrifying it
does it sounds very terrifying let me
say thanks to John Scott who is new
member number 32 it joined pakman.com
today very much appreciate your support
John thank you very much the conference
has ended we are just listening to folks
ideas about what's going on if you're
joining us on youtube please remember to
like the stream and to subscribe as well
oh I said we were almost at eight
hundred and fifteen thousand subscribers
oh wow we are we were very close we are
actually we're only 296 away there's
6500 people watching on YouTube right
now if only what is that 10 if only 3
percent of you hit the subscribe button
we will be at eight hundred and fifteen
thousand instantly which would be
amazing that's a nice round number
the real stagger wrote says can you talk
about paid leave if employers shudder
it's been mentioned we don't know what
they're going to do yet and it's not
going to apply to everybody so I Trump
said that they're looking at the way to
do it still and I don't know what
they're going to come away with don't
want to give out wrong information dave
Wampler says Trump not sniffing or
bragging it's amazing it was Chris when
it hits its peak with many many deaths
or people going to take it seriously or
go nuts
probably both Rachel Robinson says
everyone please stay smart safe and
healthy clever to swear kind of
disappointed Seema Verma didn't answer
questions I guess it wouldn't make a
difference if she spoke either way
especially after the Fox News interview
yes indeed okay on that note guys we are
gonna end our coverage for today it's
been another long day please let me know
via email if there is another one of
these tomorrow I will cover it live in
addition to the show and we will also be
live at 8 p.m. Eastern tomorrow night to
cover election results for whichever
elections take place again Ohio looking
at postponing we just learned I'll see
everybody too